[موسيقى]
هناك جمال رائع في أوكرانيا
وسط الألم والمعاناة
في مدينة أوديسا الساحلية الجنوبية ،
حاول الراقصون في بروفة ضبط
الحرب المميتة في روسيا ،
وهذا أكثر من مجرد تعبير جميل
عن الفن والثقافة
على الخلفية الرهيبة لهذه الحرب  يقدم هؤلاء
الراقصون رمزًا للتحدي
إشارة إلى أن
الأوكرانيين لا يتخلون عن
[موسيقى
] تقف أوبرا أوديسا ومسرح الباليه
مثل الجوهرة ،
وإن كانت محمية بأكياس الرمل ،
تدق الصواريخ والصواريخ الروسية
بشكل دوري
سكان أوديسا هنا الذين يتشبثون بالحياة الطبيعية قبل الحرب
و  يتضمن أوبرا المدينة التي
يبلغ عمرها 135 عامًا ،
فياتشيسلاف تشيرنوهوفوليك ، مدير الأوبرا ،
إنه جميل ، هل ما زلت
بحاجة إلى الأوبرا والباليه
عندما تكون هناك حرب رهيبة ، نعم
كل الناس بحاجة إلى هذا
،
ومن المهم جدًا أن تكون
دار الأوبرا رمزًا
للحياة الجيدة.
تسمع هذا
أداء باليه الليلة الطيبة
ولكن وسط الاستعدادات هناك
توقف
[موسيقى]
صفارة إنذار غارة جوية.  يحذر من هجوم محتمل ،
لقد دخلت الطابق السفلي ،
هذا يقول
المأوى
[الموسيقى]
الموسيقيون والراقصون ينتظرون في
الطابق السفلي ، التهديد يؤخر
بدء العرض ،
اثنان من راقصي الباليه المنفردين الليلة يحاولون
البقاء رشيقًا ،
لا ، هذا ليس طبيعيًا
لماذا تجلس  هنا
لأن
الحرب الدافئة نعم في بلدنا ، هل
تخافون
نعم بالطبع نحن خائفون يقول على
الرغم من أننا اعتدنا على هذه
التهديدات وهذا في حد ذاته أمر مروع
بعد تأخير طويل ، تجعل الأوبرا
جميع
أفراد الجمهور الواضح يخرجون من بلدهم
المأوى وأخذ مقاعدهم
في حالة التنبيه بالاسم ،
يجب على جميع الأشخاص الانتقال إلى
مجد الملجأ إلى
أوكرانيا ، حيث تملأ موسيقى شوبان
القاعة ولأقصر اللحظات
تبدو الحرب بعيدة جدًا عن
الواقع على الرغم من أن بعض هؤلاء
الفنانين أرسلوا  أطفال بعيدون بحثًا عن
الأمان في بلدان أخرى
، يدافع عدد من الفنانين وطاقم العمل
عن بلدهم الذين يخدمون في
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية بينما
يكافح أولئك الموجودون على خشبة المسرح للحفاظ على المدينة  عازفة
الروح الثقافية على قيد الحياة
كاترينا كالشينكا تعبر
نفسها قبل دخول المسرح إلى اليمين
[موسيقى]
ولكن بعد خطوات قليلة ،
أغلق الستار فجأة
الأخبار السيئة ، خرجت للتو صفارة الإنذار الثالثة للغارات الجوية في الليل
وانتهى العرض للتو  تم إيقافه ،
أريد أن يبدأ العالم بأسره في
البث ،
أخبرني أن أوقف هذا الرعب حتى يتوقف
الأبرياء والأطفال عن الموت ، لقد
طلبت المساعدة من راقصة الباليه
تقول والناس لا يلتزمون الصمت
إيفان واتسون سي إن أوديسا أوكرانيا